in Rheinlandpfalz wird das Fahren in
Bussen und Bahnen seit vier Jahren
aufwendig mit der Marke Rolf beworben es
gibt eine Website mit Erklärung zum ÖPNV
Aufkleber eine
Fahrplanauskunft die Marketingkampagne
des Landes hat satte 3 Millionen Euro
gekostet das Problem kein Mensch kennt
diesen
Rolf Rolf sagt mir jetzt überhaupt NS
habe ich noch nie
gehört jetzt in dem Zusammenhang mit B
also Rolf gar nichts ich weiß jetzt
nicht worum es geht ich weiß auch nicht
was dahinter steckt hinter Rolf Kampagne
mit Rolf wenn da keiner was mit anfangen
kann da weiß ich gar nicht was esup soll
Rolf 2019 vom reinandfelsischen
Verkehrsministerium in die Welt gesetzt
es ist ein Kunstbegriff aus der
marketingsprache RP steht für reinand
Falz das O soll Mobilität symbolisieren
und das H wird genommen damit aus rolp
Rolf wird na ja ziemlich verkopft das
ganze das eigentliche Ziel war alle
regionalen Verkehrsverbünde und
Zweckverbände sollen unter einem Begriff
zusammengefasst werden aber Rolf kommt
bei der Kundschaft nicht an setzt sich
trotz der millioneninestition nicht
durch außer Späßen nix
gewesen es ist gescheitert und es war
abzusehen weil es nicht vollumfänglich
umgesetzt wurde leider sind immer noch
die Verkehrsverbünde die am
offensichtlichsten zu erkennen sind und
Rolf war eben immer nur eine beimarke
die keiner richtig erkannt hat und das
war ein riesen Problem im inzwischen
zuständigen Mainzer
mobilitätsministerium hat man nach vier
Jahren den Glauben an Rolf verloren
schriftlich heißt es die Marke Rolf des
damaligen
Verkehrsministeriums hat sich allerdings
nicht ausreichend etablieren können um
einen ausreichenden Effekt auf die
Vermittlung des ÖPNV und seine Angebote
zu haben daher werden wir hier nachsteu
mit anderen Worten das Ministerium zieht
Rolf den Stecker er ist bald Geschichte
Rolf oder was weiß ich oder anderes hin
oder her es ist scheiße wenn die Bahn zu
spät kommt es ist scheiße wenn die Bahn
gar nicht kommt und es ist blöd wenn man
an Ticket gar nicht mehr dran kommt ich
halt von so einer Kampagne überhaupt
nichts die sollten diese Rolf Kampagne
oder das Geld was es gekostet hat lieber
innen anständig nachverkehr stecke in
den nächsten Jahren soll es in rinalz
ein neues Konzept für Mobilität geben
hoffentlich ist das dann mehr als nur
ein teurer Marketing Gag